asking the foreign secretary to extend
my warm congratulations to their
Majesty's King Charles III and queen
Camilla on their coronation
I was in Atlanta over most of the
weekend I can report that many members
of our team got up pretty early on
Saturday to watch the ceremony including
me I think it's something that
captivated millions and millions of
Americans as it did people around the
world
today I also had a chance the chance to
thank James for the United Kingdom's
crucial cooperation in getting citizens
of both of our countries out of Sudan
these joint efforts allowed UK aircraft
to evacuate more than 2 000 people
including U.S citizens
from dangerous and unpredictable
conditions and they were indispensable
to the evacuation of hundreds of
additional U.S citizens through Port
Sudan
all told we supported the evacuation of
more than thirteen hundred Americans
from Sudan in collaboration with our
partners
together now we are pressing the uh the
warring parties in Sudan to put down
their guns and allow life-saving Aid to
reach the Sudanese people
um even as we meet here we have
diplomats from the United States and
Saudi Arabia deeply engaged in talks and
Jetta working in close consultation with
counterparts from the UK the United Arab
Emirates the African Union and other
multilateral partners the collective aim
that we have is to lay the foundation
for further negotiations between the
parties that we hope can lead to a
permanent cessation of hostilities but
in the first instance we're working in
Jetta to extend the ceasefire and get
agreement on the provision of
humanitarian assistance to the people of
Sudan
we continue to engage directly with
Sudanese civilian leaders the Sudanese
Civil Society with the goal of putting
their Nation back on the track to
civilian Democratic governance that's
the goal that we share and a goal that
we will not give up on
we're also working hand in hand
as we have been for well more than a
year now
to provide support for Ukraine as it
defends its people and its territory
against Russia's war of aggression
we applaud the UK's pledge to match in
2023 the 2.3 billion dollars in Military
Support that it provided to Ukraine
during the first year of the war
in addition to training tens of
thousands of Ukrainian soldiers the UK
is providing mlrs Challenger 2 tanks
armored vehicles anti-air missiles and
other military aid that will help equip
Ukraine's Defenders as they work to
retake more of their nation's territory
in the weeks and months ahead
we also talked about the urgent need to
extend and expand the Black Sea grain
initiative
in recent days Russia has once again
returned to blocking ships from sailing
to Ukraine's ports to pick up the grain
cynical action that directly results in
less food getting to Global markets and
to human beings in Africa in the Middle
East and around the world who need that
food
while we're grateful for the tireless
efforts of Secretary General guterres
and our colleagues in Turkey working to
break the simpass
the world shouldn't need to remind
Moscow every few weeks
to stop using people's hunger as a
weapon in their war against Ukraine
we're teaming up to help rebuild Ukraine
from the Colossal damage inflicted by
Russia's Relentless attacks next month
we'll build on these efforts at the UK
hosted Ukraine recovery conference which
will bring together governments like
ours with the private sector with
International financial institutions
with multilateral organizations to
invest in the future of Ukraine and its
people
uh we also discussed how to meet other
challenges to our shared Security in
March the UK released its integrated
review refresh 2023 and its assessment
of both the challenges that we face and
how to effectively address them to work
together in that area I think we see
very very close strategic alignment that
includes when it comes to both our
individual relationships and coordinated
approach with China which we discussed
today
the vision that James set out a few
weeks ago in his speech at mansion house
underscores the shared approach when it
comes to key issues like ensuring peace
and stability across the Taiwan Strait
as well as looking for ways to cooperate
with China where we can work together to
solve big challenges
that's what people around the world
expect from great powers and it's in our
Collective interest
um
I think it's also important to note that
even as we focused today as we do on on
Ukraine on some of the challenges
represented by our respective
relationships with China
we equally focused on a much broader
agenda and that is the the needs the
concerns the imperatives for people
around the world as they deal and as we
deal with the impact of climate change
food insecurity as I've already
mentioned energy and security Global
Health trying to provide for more
inclusive economic growth
through work that we and partners in the
G7 as we're preparing for the leaders
meeting the G7 can help can help advance
and support that agenda is very much the
focus of both the United Kingdom and the
United States
James said something we were together
recently in Japan that I'll take the
liberty of quoting here he said the
world is a healthier
happier safer more prosperous place when
the United Kingdom the United States
work closely together and it's in our
mutual interest to do so
I couldn't agree more in next month's
visit by prime minister sunac to meet
with President Biden will offer us a
chance to do even more of that and we're
very much looking forward to it with
that
floor is yours
uh secretary blinken uh Tony thank you
once again for hosting me here in
Washington it's always a pleasure to
speak with you to discuss the areas of
bilateral interest as well as the issues
which affect the whole world we did so
recently at the G7 with our other
friends in the International Community
and thank you also for the kind words
that you have said on behalf of your
nation on the coronation of his majesty
King Charles III and queen Camilla and
can I also thank the first lady for
joining us at this time of special
celebration uh once in a lifetime event
made more special because we're able to
share it with friends from across the
world
can also put on record our thanks to the
United States America and indeed you
personally for the huge amount of effort
that you have invested in seeking peace
in Sudan it was a situation which
unfolded whilst we were meeting at the
G7 in Japan and I commend the effort
that you personally put in engaging with
the generals with the leadership of the
warring factions to try and bring
initially a ceasefire and then your
ongoing work the ongoing work of the
United States of America in trying to
broker a sustainable piece it should
remind everybody that whilst we are of
course working on the support that we
give to a Ukraine and their self-defense
and I'll touch upon that again in a
moment
we are not distracted from the pressing
issues of the day and we deal with them
we deal with them effectively we deal
with them collaboratively and we are
able to do so because of the very strong
bilateral relationship that our two
countries enjoy a relationship which is
invested in regularly by the visits that
we make over here and as you say I know
the prime minister is very much looking
forward to meeting with President Biden
when he comes across next month but also
we are very grateful to the president
for his recent visit to the United
Kingdom to celebrate the 25th
anniversary of the Good Friday agreement
um a topic which I know is of a great
interest and passion to him and we value
your country's engagement on that issue
we remain committed to building peace
and prosperity around the world just as
we are attempting to do in Sudan and we
continue to work towards that goal in
Ukraine
every time I come to the United States I
make a point of thanking your nation for
the scale of support that you have given
to Ukraine you are the largest donor
both in Military and economic terms and
I know that your support is incredibly
important in their ability to defend
themselves against this unprovoked
attack from Russia we of course spoke at
length about
the nature of that support about the
next few months and the importance to
not only look at the context through the
prism of the conflict but also to focus
on the future rebuilding work that will
inevitably
be needed we are very pleased the UK is
very pleased to host on behalf of
Ukraine UK recovery conference where we
will seek to build a coalition
that will enable Ukraine to rebuild its
country after this conflict has been
concluded after they regain their
country back and we value the United
States of America's uh coordinating role
in ensuring that the private sector as
well as the public sector is heavily
involved in that Reconstruction from
UK's point of view we will of course
also continue to provide financial and
military aid we intend to give the
ukrainians the tools they need to
successfully defend themselves Against
The Invasion
but just as we did with Sudan we remain
focused on the needs of some of the
poorest people in the world and I Echo
your comments on the Black Sea Green
initiative it is completely wrong that
Russia uses the hunger of some of the
poorest people in the world to pursue
leverage during this conflict they
should re-sign the Black Sea grade
initiative and do so immediately they
should unlock the supply of food
to go to those people around the world
who need it most and it is perverse that
they are using hunger in the developing
world as leverage in their conflict in
Ukraine
we did of course also have the
opportunity to speak about issues uh uh
on a broader context and of course how
we uh
recognize the role that China has in
world affairs and how we respond to
China's action will of course be an
ongoing part of our bilateral
discussions
I recently gave a major speech on the
UK's
posture towards China which was derived
from our recent integrated review
refresh we made the point that we need
to defend ourselves as Nations the UK is
doing this as indeed the United States
of America is against inappropriate
activities by China we also need to make
sure that we build alliances and
strengthen the pre-existing alliances
that we have as I'm doing today with the
United States of America but also with
our friends in the indo-pacific region
and we have to engage with China
directly robustly regularly to seek to
influence the decisions that are made in
Beijing and do so in a way that benefits
the whole world whether that be on the
maintenance of peace across the Taiwan
Strait which of course is something
which affects all of us irrespective of
where we are in the world to issues such
as climate change
pandemic prevention and response
and that of course brings us uh full
circle to our bilateral relations with
the United States of America we have
been uh close uh defense Partners we are
intelligent sharing partners and of
course we have strong economic ties and
we will seek to find Opportunities where
the UK can be a strong economic partner
to the United States of America as well
as being a strong defensive partner as
well
um it is
and thank you for reminding me of that
quote I I do happen to be rather proud
of it I think it is in our mutual
interest and in the interests of
everyone around the world that the UK
and U.S bilateral relationship continues
to be one of the uh uh points of Pride
and one which is strong and one which I
intend to make even stronger still in
the future thank you
we'll take four questions uh first Kylie
Atwood from CNN
questions
um secretary blinken I want to just ask
you a quick question on China and then
pivot to Ukraine
um this meet this week when Ambassador
Burns met with the Chinese foreign
minister did they agree to begin
planning on your rescheduled visit to
Beijing
and then on Ukraine does Ukraine have
what it needs to be successful in
winning back at least some of the
territory that Russia is now occupying
in the upcoming counter-offensive and
secretary cleverley the same question
for you does Ukraine have everything it
needs to be successful in winning back
some of that territory and then
specifically related to International
support for Ukraine and headed into the
coming months and year there are reports
that your country is preparing to send
long-range missiles to Kiev when could
those long-range missiles from the UK
and potentially other European allies
actually arrive in the country and we
have seen in the past that when the UK
moves on an additional military
capability for Ukraine the U.S has
followed suit in any of your
conversations so far have you gotten
indications that that might be the case
with long-range missile systems as well
thank you thank you thank you Carly
thanks very much happy to happy to start
uh with regard to China I'm obviously
not going to go into any detail about
the investors conversations with Chinese
counterparts uh what I can say is this
what we have communicated
to um
our colleagues in the government in
Beijing is the importance from our
perspective in engagement precisely
because we have a deeply complicated and
also consequential relationship that uh
is important to people in the United
States and China but beyond that around
the world that our two presidents agreed
when they met in Bali at the end of last
year that it would be important to um
establish and strengthen our lines of
communication and that we believe that
that's in our interests and also
something that the rest of the world
expects us to do because there's an
expectation that we will responsibly
manage the relationship and precisely
because we have
profound differences as well as I
believe some responsibility not only to
manage those differences so that the
competition that we have doesn't vary
into conflict but also
the potential where it's in our mutual
interest and where it answers needs that
the the world has as well to find areas
of cooperation that engagements the way
that we
try to pursue both of those
responsibilities so that's the the
nature of the uh the conversation that
we're having
with uh with China in this moment and
we'll see where that where that goes
with regard to to Ukraine uh all along
from day one in fact before day one uh
it's been our determination to make sure
that Ukraine has what it needs to
effectively defend itself against the
Russian aggression and throughout
the more than one year of that
aggression we have worked very hard to
adjust
um
every step of the way to what was needed
at any given time and right now of
course the focus is on the Ukrainian
efforts that we anticipate to try to
retake more of the territory that's been
seized from Ukraine by Russia over the
last the last 14 plus months
um
I believe that the efforts that both of
us have been deeply engaged in
are
very uh
productive in terms of what more than I
think 50 countries
have been able to provide Ukraine
secretary Austin has been leading a
process as you know for many months
where we have a coordinated process to
do that
and as I've said repeatedly it's not
only
the weapons it's the training and the UK
has been engaged in significant training
it's making sure that the ukrainians can
maintain the systems that we provide
them and it's important of course that
they have uh the right plans again to be
successful
my own estimation is that they have in
place across all of those Dimensions
what they need to continue to be
successful in regaining territory that
was seized by force by Russia over the
last 14 months
uh Kylie thank you um
I'm going to take slight issue with one
of the elements in your in your question
but you know thank you for highlighting
that the the UK has been very proactive
in our support for Ukraine
um we are very proud of the fact that we
provided the anti-tank the handheld
anti-tank missile systems ahead of the
February of last year's Invasion by
Russia and those pieces of equipment
improved very consequential in Ukraine's
defense of Kiev
but I also think it's important that we
put on record that the United States
from the very start has been very active
very effective in its support and as
befits a country of the scale and power
of the United States America it is the
largest donor of the of the Allies so I
wouldn't want to imply that there's
either kind of competition between us or
anything else we have from the very
start worked in close coordination the
nature of our militaries is different
the natures of our political systems are
different there are some things that the
UK is able to do more quickly because of
the nature of our political system
and there are some things that the
America the the American system allows
them to do different and better it's not
about always trying to replicate what
our allies do that's not the point of
Alliance the appoint the point of an
alliance is that we support each other
that we reinforce each other in our
work to help Ukraine defend itself and
as secretary blinken said we constantly
assess
and coordinate with each other and with
ukrainians to make sure that the support
that we are giving them matches the
needs at the time those anti-tank
missiles at the early stages air defense
systems more recently the training of
their ground troops the uh provision of
armored vehicles and ammunition and the
ability for them to project effective
Force against Russian troops within
Ukraine to push them out of their
country and we will continue to do so it
is a collaborative effort it has proven
to be very very effective and what we've
seen over and over again is that the
Ukrainian both political the ukrainians
both politically and militarily
have learned quickly have been
relentlessly focused on using the
support that we give them effectively
and have consistently outperformed
expectations certainly the expectations
of Vladimir Putin
well you would I'm sure understand that
anything to do with operational details
about the nature the timing the scale of
our support would be counterproductive
for us to uh discuss publicly we'll next
go to Mark stone with Sky News
uh thank you both very much um secretary
blinken a question for you in a moment
if I may but first of all for uh for
foreign secretary cleverly um it feels
as though support for Ukraine is waning
a little bit um you may disagree with
that but you can feel it on Capitol Hill
with influential sections of the
Republican party and their base Across
America skeptical now about the uh
never-ending seemingly never-ending
support for Ukraine if ukrainians don't
deliver a decisive victory over the next
few months how do you how does Britain
persuade America that they must continue
to lead support for Ukrainian Victory
and if you can't what then
and a second question for you if I can
just just a little bit more on the um
the long-range missiles can you give us
any assessment of whether these
long-rangement missiles will come and
what effect that will have on the
battlefield and then in a moment for you
sir well uh I I I I've said this uh
so why don't you put your question okay
sorry I will yeah of course so blinking
um I want to focus with you on American
priorities if I may
um since Ukraine um since the war
started there have been nearly 9 000
civilian casualties in Ukraine according
to the UN in America this year in the
past five months 15 000 people have died
from gun violence 70 000 people died
last year from opioid overdoses many of
those drugs coming from China your
argument on defending Ukraine is clear
but with so many fundamental challenges
here at home and politicians telling
people that security begins at home how
do you maintain support for a battle far
away thank you
especially on our support for Ukraine
and when I say our I mean
the the the the wider Alliance of
friends who are supported Ukraine which
means the UK and the United States of
America and others
we need to recognize that the outcome of
this conflict will have effect
all over the the world I've said over
and over again the eyes of the world are
watching they are watching how we
respond to this challenge they are
watching to see our resolve and uh
whether it be in capital cities or
non-state actors the message that we
send now is really important
I think the message that we should send
is that when we commit to something we
stick with it we have the grip we have
the determination we have the Strategic
endurance to see it through until it's
successful conclusion and anyone
watching should learn that lesson I
would also make the point that of course
there has been an economic impact on
people in the United States of America
and in the United Kingdom this is not a
byproduct of Russia's invasion of
Ukraine this is part of the conflict
economic coercion through their
restrictions of hydrocarbons uh pinching
off the supply of grain to the
developing world this is part of the
conflict is not a byproduct of the
conflict and we should recognize that if
we do not re-establish the principles of
the UN Charter the uh the the the the
foundation stone of Peace in the
post-second World War era that powerful
Nations cannot invade their neighbors
with impunity the world will be more
dangerous more expensive more difficult
so this is not just about Ukraine though
of course the ukrainians have been
suffering enormously and it's right that
we defend them it is about us and it is
in our interest as well as the
ukrainian's interests that we stay
Resolute in our support because it will
become paying for the more expensive if
we do not and when it comes to the uh
the ukrainians uh forthcoming
counter-offensive I I I've made the
point that this is this is not a film
uh there are no certainties when it
comes to conflict the ukrainians have
consistently outperformed uh
expectations but there can be no
guarantees in war so we have to
recognize that we are giving ukrainians
a huge amount of support as I said they
have learned quickly they have adapted
very very successfully and they have
defended themselves incredibly
effectively and we need to continue to
support them
irrespective of whether this uh
forthcoming offensive
generates you know huge gains on the on
the battlefield because until this
conflict is resolved and resolved
properly
it is not over and that's the message
that I have spoken about back home in
the UK and I will continue to say to
those friends and colleagues here in the
United States of America as well
thank you first
I can only
violently agree with my friend and
strongly endorse what what he just said
we have exactly the same perspective
second I would also dispute the notion
of waning support I would refer you for
example just recently to the very strong
statement made by the Speaker of the
House
McCarthy about support for Ukraine and
the enduring support and determination
to see this through
but stepping back there is not a
zero-sum choice between
some of the work that we're doing around
the world and the work that we're doing
at home in fact to the contrary
they're directly linked and they're
mutually reinforcing we've spent the
last couple of years
making historic Investments
in in ourselves infrastructure our
technological Edge when it comes to
semiconductors making sure that the
United States would continue to lead
when it comes to dealing with climate
change and producing the technology of
the future Green Technology for for
green economies at the same time
working closely with our partners
we've revitalized re-engaged our
alliances our Partnerships we built new
ones the net result is that we are
stronger at home and are standing around
the world is at I think the highest
level that I've seen in in recent years
and of course
we are
I was going to say walking and chewing
gum running and chewing gum at the same
time even as we are engaged in helping
Ukraine defend itself against the social
aggression for all the reasons the
foreign secretary laid out and as he
said earlier we are equally focused on a
very broad Global agenda that addresses
the needs and concerns of people around
the world as well as our own citizens
and of course we're focused on
challenges that we we have at home you
mentioned opioids uh synthetic opioids
like like fentanyl we're relentlessly
focused on that and that is by
definition a problem that is both local
and global
we're in the in the midst of building a
much stronger Global coalition
to deal with the ravages that fentanyl
is producing in the United States it's
the number one killer of Americans
between the ages of 18 and 49.
uh so this is right at the top of our
agenda and of course we're working very
hard at home to deal with demand to deal
with treatment to deal with recovery at
the same time we're working very closely
including with our neighbor Mexico on
the law enforcement piece to break up
the cartels to break up the financing to
interrupt the distribution but more
broadly we're also working to get at the
global Network that has the production
of some of the chemicals that go into
fentanyl being made halfway around the
world and then coming close to us
perhaps getting diverted into the
illicit production of Fentanyl and then
winding up in the United States that's
exactly what the Coalition that we're
that we're building and more on that in
the in the coming weeks we'll uh we'll
work we'll work to address
we know that in the United States when
it comes to Fentanyl and synthetic
opioids to some extent we've been the
canary in the coal mine it hit us first
and it's it's hit us very hard but as
the markets become saturated in the
United States we see criminal
Enterprises trying to make markets
elsewhere in the world including in
Europe including in Asia and there is a
growing awareness and urgency on the
part of other countries to making sure
that we're tackling this problem so
that's exactly what we're doing and
we're not only doing it at home we're
doing it by building a very strong
partnership with other countries with
the private sector and other
institutions to engage on it so the
bottom line is these are not zero-sum
choices these are responsibilities we
have dealing with challenges we have at
home dealing with challenges we have
around the world and understanding the
connections that exist between them
we'll next go to Sean Tandon with the
AFP
hi there good afternoon
um another uh conflict that's caused a
lot of suffering in Syria
um uh just two days ago the Arab League
voted to readmit Syria uh to both of you
do you see this at all as a failure of
the efforts to isolate Assad that have
been going on for many years uh
specifically to secretary blinken
um across partisan lines in Congress the
calls to continue using the Caesar act
and other authorities to prevent
normalization with Assad this is still
something that can be done
um despite the reconciliation but the
Arab League and by turkey for that
matter with with the Assad regime uh and
to foreign secretary cleverly on that
note as well
um does the United does the United
Kingdom agree with the U.S approach of
no reconstruction Aid at this point
where as long as Assad is there is that
the approach that that you think is
beneficial and just briefly if I could
ask both of you if any of you thought
any thoughts on the events today in
Pakistan uh former prime minister Khan
was arrested there's some violence if
you have any thoughts on that thanks
okay
Sean thank you um let me uh let me
address Syria first
um a few things on that um
we do not believe that Syria merits
readmission to the Arab League
it's a point we've made to all of our
regional Partners but they have to make
make their own decisions and our
position is clear we are not going to be
in the business of normalizing relations
with uh with Assad and with that regime
uh having said that we also clearly have
shared goals when it comes to Syria with
our partners and I think that's
reflected in a number of the things that
that they've said first ultimately the
only solution to the crisis inflicted on
Syria by Assad has to be consistent with
the U.N security Council resolution 2254
that lays out expectations for a
ceasefire for uh humanitarian assistance
and for free and fair elections to
ensure that syrians have a government
that actually reflects the will of the
Syrian people we agree on the importance
of the imperative of expanding
humanitarian access to Syria we agree on
the importance of continuing the work to
degrade Isis or Dash to make sure that
it can't re-emerge and we agree on the
importance of reducing Iran's malign
influence and presence in Syria as well
as more broadly in the region
so I think the our perspective is uh
articulated uh through the the Arab
League is they believe that they can
pursue these objectives through more
direct engagement but the we may have a
different perspective when it comes to
that but the objectives that we have uh
I think are the same
so that's where the the focus is
I think it's also fair to say that in
terms of what's happened over the last
few years
what we set out to do is to work to try
to stabilize as best we could
from afar the the situation to ensure as
I said that Isis cannot re-emerge in
Syria to expand humanitarian access and
on those criteria I think we've actually
made some progress
fewer syrians have lost their lives in
the last few years it's a it's a
unfortunately a low a low bar given the
horrors of the last decade but that is a
fact we've taken Isis leaders off the
battlefield to ensure that again that
organization couldn't re-emerge in the
way that it at one point controlled a
huge chunk of Syria and use it as a base
for potential attacks around the world
and the humanitarian Aid has continued
to flow in fact we've managed to expand
it and we even managed to continue it
despite the horrific earthquake in Syria
so I think if you look at those various
metrics
um we have made some some progress and
again with our partners even if we
disagree on the readmission to the Arab
League the objectives that we have uh
remain the same
um and with regard to Pakistan of course
I've seen the uh the reports uh
that that you've alluded to and uh we uh
we just want to make sure that whatever
happens in Pakistan is consistent with
the rule of law with the Constitution
uh Sean yes
again this is an occasion where the UK
and the US uh share very very similar
views I had a number of conversations
with our interlocutors in the region uh
ahead of the formal announcement of
Syria's readmission
I say to you now what I said to uh our
friends in in the region that the UK is
very uncomfortable
with Syria's re-admission to the Arab
League but as secretary Lincoln said
ultimately it is a decision for the
membership of the Arab League the point
that I have made is that there needs to
be conditionality if they choose to take
this course of action have they done it
as they have done it needs to be
conditional on some fundamental changes
of behavior from Damascus and from the
Assad regime the protection of syrians
if they choose to go back to Syria from
the refugee camps in the region needs to
be assured the
excuse Council resolution 2254 needs to
be at the heart of any engagement with
Syria and we cannot
we cannot just wish away
the actions of the Assad regime over the
last few years the brutality against
Syrian people cannot just be ignored and
the UK certainly won't brush that under
the carpet but we do recognize that
there is a huge amount of pressure on
countries in the region they seek to
alleviate that pressure through
engagement with the Assad government in
uh or the Assad regime in Damascus let's
say if if they are going to do that then
my strong view is that they should make
sure
that any steps that they take are more
than matched by fundamental changes in
behavior from the Assad regime and
commitments that are then adhered to
inline with 2254. again with regard to
Pakistan I've seen the headlines I've
not yet had the opportunity to be
briefed in detail
the UK has a long-standing and close
relationship with Pakistan we are a
commonwealth Partners we want to see a
peaceful
democracy in that country we want to see
the rule of law adhered to I'm
uncomfortable to speculate any further
without having a detailed briefing on
that
well final question go to Nick Allen of
the telegraph
thank you um if I could turn to trade
please
um secretary blinken how do you address
concerns on the other side of the
Atlantic about the inflation reduction
act what do you say to allies who might
feel it's protectionists at their
expense
and foreign secretary
um in the absence of an FDA and with the
emergence of the inflation reduction act
What specifically are you pushing for to
boost joint Economic Security and the
bilateral investment relationship
between the two countries for example
was there any discussion today about
critical minerals and a deal similar to
the one with Japan
thank you
um
I think as we've said
over these last months
our primary focus with the inflation
reduction Act
was making sure that we're making the
appropriate investments in ourselves
to make sure that we can deliver when it
comes to continuing to produce the
technologies that are necessary both for
dealing with the the climate crisis and
that we're going to be I think
Central to 21st century economies and
that's what the uh the ACT is all about
this is a historic commitment
to dealing with with climate and also a
historic commitment to making sure that
our economy is producing the very things
that will be
front and center
for economies around the world over the
next decades
but as we've also said very clearly the
intent is is broader than that in terms
of making sure that
um collectively
with countries around the world that
have a similar approach and are of
similar mind that we're working together
to build the strongest possible
Collective infrastructure Supply chains
ecosystem to um to produce those
Technologies and
we've also worked to make sure that to
the extent there were any
unintended consequences coming from the
act that we uh that we've addressed
those and that's what we've been working
to do I think successfully over the
recent months this is not at all a zero
sum on the contrary I think it offers
the prospects for a collective race to
the top not raised to the bottom when it
comes to both addressing the climate
crisis and making sure that our
economies are producing the very
technologies that are going to be front
and center in the 21st century global
economy and making sure that our
countries collectively are doing that
and that we are producing the strongest
possible Diversified and resilient
Supply chains all of these things are
connected I think they're profound
benefits in the um in the ira
for many of our partners around the
world because again we will be
increasingly joined in a
in a supply chain that that we've been
working to build so I suspect that um
when the prime minister is here we'll
continue that conversation as the
foreign secretary said we continue to
look at ways to strengthen and deepen
what is already an extraordinarily
strong economic partnership between our
countries
uh Nick um I know
ftas are often used as a shorthand for
closer uh economic Partnerships we are
not prioritizing FTA with the United
States of America because there are many
areas where we can work more closely
more collaboratively have real economic
coordination that does not require
the traditional kind of tariff reducing
elements of an FDA one of the advantages
of being able to speak directly and
regularly is the ability to coordinate
and make sure that the completely
understandable
and correct desire of every government
to make sure that it protects itself
against future economic coercion for
example that it protects itself against
pinch points of uh critical elements of
its supply chain
and that is right and proper that
governments seek to do that but in doing
so
um also seeks the opportunity to work
closely with like-minded friends and
economic allies in the same way that we
are amongst the strongest defensive
allies in the world as two member states
of NATO we are intelligent sharing
Partners through the five eyes
intelligence sharing a relationship the
UK is also seeking to build an economic
Alliance which protects the interests of
the United States of America while
simultaneously protecting the UK's
interests protects standards
uh protects against the use of
constrictions of key elements of Global
Supply chains as a form of political uh
or as a form of coercion
um and and all these things are best
done in close coordination which is why
uh whether it's in Japan or in London or
in Washington or anywhere else we always
take the opportunity to discuss as we as
we do the situation in Ukraine those
other immediate pressing issues but also
some of the long-term ways that we can
work more collaboratively to protect
those things that Tony quoted that I've
said in the past the things that make us
healthier and wealthier and more
prosperous and safer and I have no doubt
that when my prime minister comes to the
United States next month they'll be very
much on the agenda that he discusses
with President Biden think your
excellencies thank you
thank you